to know that they look up to me
um I thought that would be a bunch of
pressure but it's actually it makes me
strive to be a better father and to set
a really good example and my wife and I
police supporter and her sister and two
years later AJ McLean's words ring true
to be a dad is honestly the best job the
Backstreet Boy and his wife Rochelle
revealing their nine-year-old daughter
changed her name from Ava to Elliot
Rochelle explains the update on
Instagram sharing why she and AJ are
totally supportive of the swap quote Ava
has changed her name quite a few times
since she was about five last year she
asked us to start calling her Elliot and
it stopped she wanted something unique
that no one else had Rochelle also
clarifies that the name switch is not a
gender thing quote I didn't really see
the harm in respecting her desire to be
unique
[Music]
the mom of two goes on to say she finds
it odd that kids are expected to Forever
identify with the names chosen by their
parents an admit she knew people would
have opinions but calls for kindness on
behalf of her daughter quote she's just
a kid trying to make her way in this
crazy world I just want her to know she
can always be whoever she wants to be my
Wonder Woman as I call her my amazing
super wife she's the one that holds down
the fort the name change reveal came the
same day as these sweet snaps the McLean
celebrating Elliot's first day of school
along her little sister lyric she's the
spitting image of me her personality yes
she is and it's just like the coolest
thing in the world in the pick the girls
hold up balloons to Mark the New Year
One Reading Elliot's first day of fourth
grade the other Lyric's first day of
kindergarten it's literally the most
rewarding thing I've ever done in my
life to be to be a father there's no
better job there's no better gift than
when I come home to be received with
hugs and kisses and cuddles from my
girls
foreign
[Music]